so I argue in favor of genetically
modified foods I argue in favor of
nuclear power and I oh you're in favor
of at least being ready to use a geo
engineering technology hi I'm Ron daily
with recent television today on recent
TV we have Ramez nom he is a
professional technologist a former
Microsoft executive in a fellow with
Institute of ethics and emerging
technologies is also the author of more
than human embracing the promise of
biological enhancement a wonderful
transhumanist book and a science fiction
novel nexus today we're going to talk
about his new book the infinite resource
the power of ideas on a finite planet
welcome thanks Ron so why did you write
the infinite resource I decided several
years ago that I need to understand for
myself what I thought the state of the
planet and humanity was and that led to
years of research and that led me to the
conclusion that we have serious problems
but that we're capable of fixing them so
what is the chief message do you think
readers should take away from your book
it's mostly a message of optimism but
it's not a complacent optimism it's an
optimism derived from our ability to
solve problems if we act what do you
mean by the air well I think there's
several problems that I talk about in
the book climate change being chief
among them but also fresh water
depletion ocean overfishing and so on so
in most of those cases innovation is Lee
the key to success their problems where
we can end up richer at the other side
if we devote our energies to innovating
and technology and in economics how do
you solve some of those problems it
seems to me one of the arguments that
I've been trying to make it for many
years is that wherever you see an
environmental problem of the sort that
you're talking about they're happening
in an open-access common so basically
there are defective property rights no
one owns resource there but they're
there by everybody over abuses it and it
over exploits it is that the central
problem with these that is absolutely
correct you also worried about peak oil
I understand why are you worried about
peak oil well I know it's not your
interest I'm so aren't you enter
estimating the inventiveness of people
in the fossil fuel industry well I know
it's no longer fashionable to worry
about peak oil but we had a series of
reports so last year the IE
a the international energy agency came
out and said oh my gosh there's so much
oil when you look at their projections
they predicted oil going up at about 0.5
percent per year in supply while demand
goes up at two percent per year and so
they saw oil nominal dollars going up to
two hundred dollars a barrel twice what
it is today and the IEA in their last
ten projections on oil have been over
optimistic in nine of them so this is
the most optimistic agency you have and
their projection that people cite it in
the process hugely optimistic is
actually fairly gloomy we haven't
reached the top yet oil production is
going to keep going up but each barrel
is more expensive than the last you seem
to be fairly optimistic about that once
you get the property regimes correct or
the tax regime correct you seem very
optimistic that the markets should be
able to bring forth the innovations to
overcome these problems why is that it's
what we've done historically in the past
when we passed the Montreal Protocol to
phase out CFCs that were damaging the
ozone layer industry protested industry
took the pessimistic view that this
would end economic growth there were
claims that you would no longer be able
to refrigerate medicines and hospitals
and so on and we didn't have our
replacement for CFCs two years later we
did so once the economic incentive is
there in this case you have to keep your
business running people innovate and
find new ways to meet that same need
with less externalities so you think
that this is a virtuous process that
will continue into the future if we get
it right it will if you if you combine
that historical view with the technical
view of what's actually possible in
energy for instance in water and food
you find us in the basic physical
numbers of how much energy there is
available there's a huge supply that we
can tap into so those two things
together say if we make the right
choices and the right incentives
economically we can prosper so now that
you have a touching faith in the genius
of government bureaucrat you advocate
among many other things to do so long if
you will or boost along a technical
technological innovation that we should
increase government are in
II why do you think that government
bureaucrats are smart enough to do this
and people in the private sector or not
I'm not sure that they are any smarter I
don't think that they are but there are
certain types of research that
government rd can get a higher ROI on
than in the private sector so for
instance sometimes there is research
that has a longer time horizon then most
private sector companies have the
resources to be able to invest in for
example and then when you look at a
government in your example give me such
a technology well i think in solar
actually a lot of the early work that
led to AT&T Bell Labs is final
possession of solar photovoltaics came
out of the US labs for instance and
you'll see a lot of the work in battery
technologies in the future for instance
in metal air batteries a lot of that was
done by the current of energy
researchers and is now being privatized
by private companies to produce those
the other thing I'd say is that the
amount that we're talking about spending
in government rd is tiny so the u.s. in
green energy right now spends four to
five billion dollars in R&D okay that's
less than the amount that Americans band
on hair products each year it's not a
very large amount Bill Gates's proposal
is to triple that to 16 billion at which
point it would still not show up on any
large-scale view of the budget if you
will that's a tiny tiny amount but has
incredibly high ROI when done right in
the book you mentioned that you are
argue in favor of three different
unthinkable technologies what are those
technologies and why are they
unthinkable yes so I are you in favor of
genetically modified foods I argue in
favor of nuclear power and I oh you're
in favor of at least being ready to use
a geo engineering technologies all of
these are sort of environmental Bugaboos
if you will or their Anathem o to the
environmental movement but they all have
either very real khuvon benefits or
important potential benefits so with
GMOs the conclusion of every scientific
panels look at this the National
Academies of science in the US for
instance is that they're safe for humans
and they've actually improve
moved the environment where they're
deployed on the horizon we have new GMOs
that could increase crop yields and I
remember we have to feed seventy percent
more food productions what we need by
2050 so we can increase crop yields GMOs
that could fertilize themselves from the
atmosphere that are drought resistant
that can grow in saltier areas those are
all wonderful things for the environment
and for people at the same time nuclear
power when you look at the environmental
consequences of nuclear power versus
coal which is the the most common from
electricity today you find that it's
it's orders of magnitude different
nuclear power over the entire history
has killed at most a few thousand people
air pollution from coal probably kills a
hundred thousand people a year that's a
low estimate right now in fact the
radiation in the fly ash from a coal
plant per kilowatt hour produced is more
than the radiation in a nuclear plant of
similar size so it's clear that nuclear
is a better technology than one of the
old ones we're using and while solar is
wonderful it doesn't provide a lot of
power at night batteries might get us
there but it's nice to have an
alternative as well nice to have more
than one bet going on as far as
technologies we can employ and then
there's go to climate engineering you
meant that as a as an unthinkable
technology so so here's the thing right
now it does not look like we're on path
for stopping climate change before we
reach some danger points and my danger
points I mean things like the melting of
the Arctic sea ice right now is exposing
darker waters underneath that itself
helps heat up the planet and that could
liberate trillion tons of greenhouse
gases trapped in the Arctic mithi
inverter exactly so we don't want to
reach that tipping point and there's
great uncertainty we don't know exactly
when it will happen so it sort of just
gambling a little bit here so we need
some backup plan we need some plan of if
we're unable to reduce co2 emissions
fast enough or if some of these tipping
points get reached what can we do and
there's two forms of climate engineering
we could employ one is sucking Co
you out either of the smokestacks of
factories or power plants or open
atmosphere and seek Western it in the
ground it's a good kind of sequestration
the other is actually reflecting more
sunlight into space with aerosols
injected high in the atmosphere and they
both could use tremendously more R&D in
order to just have them as options and
to evaluate whether matt not they might
be very good options in some cases you
argue that we can buy some if you will
climate change insurance fairly cheaply
how would we do that all right why do
you say it's cheap well it's cheap in
comparison so right now worldwide if you
hurdle up every kind of insurance that
we buy life insurance property insurance
etc etc the world spends almost seven
percent with GDP on insurance that's a
tremendous number it surprised me I did
research for the book various people's
estimates of how much of global gdp it
would take to combat climate change
effectively range from one percent to
two percent I'd make a case that if use
our revenue neutral carbon tax the
actual impact on GDP is much much
smaller than that so that's relatively
cheap to guard against what is a a risk
of a somewhat unknown timing and
severity of when it arrives we know the
climate is warming but predicting
exactly how much its way too warm and
how bad it's going to be when that
happens is very difficult and the worst
cases of that are so bad that they are
really something that it's worth
investing in preventing so if we do
things right what will the year 2100
look like it's it's so tough to look
that far in the future but I think if
you look around the world at what's
happening now you'll see that by 2100 we
might have 25 year longer lifespans on
average that's without any breakthrough
and biotechnology that's just the trends
you're looking at a global GDP of close
to a quadrillion dollars you're looking
at the poor of the world having more
richness more affluence more wealth than
a rich American
right now I mean as an example so that
today already a poor person in China or
say somebody in the middle in China has
much more wealth in a lot of ways than a
Rockefeller did they have cell phones
they have travel options that the rich
is the richest people of 1900 certainly
did not have and that's what I think
we'll see as well in 2100 relatives
right now thank you very much it's been
an interesting conversation good luck on
the book thank you